homelessness is a problem that's in many
ways just like puberty right which is
not like homelessness is just like
puberty
in the sense that there's genetic
effects on people's biology and then
there's how our social and legal
environment response to that in the u.s
a serious mental illness is one of the
biggest risk factors for being homeless
it seems like you've had a spicy few
years
of controversy do you think that's fair
to say
um i don't think i've ever heard the
word spicy before to describe it but i
do think that it's fair to say that
there's been a couple years of
controversy yes i'm pretty fascinated by
your positioning because doing
behavioral genetics which
for good or for ill has kind of been
adopted by some people on the right
um but
your political leanings are toward the
left so you occupy this sort of very
difficult space in between why why do
you think it is that you consistently
find yourself in the eye of the storm of
these debates
that is a very good question that i've
asked myself
on a number of occasions recently
you know i
i think there are people that walk into
things
sort of deliberately courting
controversy sort of seeing okay what can
i say that's going to be provocative and
that genuinely has not been
kind of my approach or experience it
really has kind of felt
this kind of bewildering dislocating
experience in which i say things that
seem just true to me and then it is only
by saying them out loud that i realize
that they are
controversial and and in fact almost
never controversial
when each statement is taken
on its own it's something about the
combination of them like the package of
them that seems to provoke strong
feelings um
but you know like i'm a professor i'm an
academic i feel like i have this great
privilege of getting to think about
things that i think are important and
thinking out loud about them with my
students and in my research papers and
then more recently with kind of more
public-facing work
and my goal in all of this has just been
to really articulate like what do i
think is true like what do i think is
true from a scientific perspective
and what do i think is true
in terms of
um expressing my own personal like
political and moral convictions
and it just turns out that if you
repeatedly say true things
um in this space that seems to rile up
um pretty strong feelings i think on
both sides of the political spectrum
which is interesting why do you think
people are so uncomfortable with
behavioral genetics generally
oh
you know there's this really great paper
by
a legal scholar dov fox where he talks
about genetics and to a lesser
neuroscience as subversive science and i
love that phrase the verse of science
and he's what he's arguing is that
it can subvert
really basic intuitions that we have
about um agency or equality
i don't actually think it has to be
subversive in quite those ways i think
sometimes the perceived subversiveness
of behavioral genetics
rests on misunderstandings of it like if
properly understood many of the fears of
the ways that genetics will subvert our
values of equality or agency or identity
um
you know turn out to not be true
but
we live in a secular age in which people
often don't believe in souls anymore and
so they've substituted genes as kind of
their essence placeholders is the way
that some people talk about it
and so
when you start talking about genetics i
think ultimately you're talking about
people's selves you're talking you're
talking about things about themselves
that they they value or cherish or fear
um or things they see in their children
so
you know to some extent
i don't think that you can talk about
genetics and humans without there being
some emotion attached to it and that's
probably a good thing that we want to
preserve
our sense of something
um
something sacred about our humanness
even in a secular age yeah sacred is the
word that i had on the tip of my tongue
there as well you think about
the successes that you have the failures
that you have the things you value in
yourself the idiosyncrasies your
inclination toward playing this sport or
not toward having a family or not
all of these things we like to consider
ourselves as having some sort of agency
and
yeah
the
conception that you can be anything that
you want to be that living in a
meritocracy where you get to choose your
own roots that your failures and your
successes are yours to bear there's a
lot of uh waves clashing it's like the
bermuda triangle
of awkward tidal forces all crashing
against each other
yeah no i think that's true there is
something that we
[Music]
um
i think many modern people
resist the idea of
constraint the idea that there is
constraint
you know that that we are not just these
kind of like disembodied minds that have
free and infinite potential to choose
any future for ourselves but in fact
even many of our choices are constrained
by like our embodied biology i think
people find that idea really
um alienating and then i also think you
know people it's not just genetics um
you know there's this quote in my book
from the novelist and sas bb white like
most people know him from the children's
book charlotte's web but he also wrote
um for the new yorker for many years and
has this book of essays
and
there's a quote from it which is you
can't speak of luck to a self-made man
and he's what he's getting out there is
that when you've had some success there
is a lot of our psychology that kind of
kicks in to justify it as like i earned
this like look how hard i worked for
this
and
people can feel
enraged actually when you say well you
worked for it but also that work was
scaffolded by all of this luck and some
of that luck is environmental and some
of that luck is sort of your embodied
biology
i think people can often feel like
you're trying to take their success away
from them or take away a source of pride
away from them which is not what i'm
trying to do
um i think i'm more trying to engender a
sense of
of gratitude that you've been given
things that you know you you didn't earn
you didn't necessarily deserve and also
a sense of compassion for people who
haven't had the same luck um in certain
ways what are you trying to do with this
book then
that's such a good question you know i
asked myself all the time like how did i
get myself into this um
i'm trying to do a couple different
things so i think i'm trying to
one just
explain what genetics is up to these
days right like a lot of times you hear
this phrase we're in the middle of a dna
revolution and i think we are from the
perspective of
science's ability to measure
people's dna directly cheaply
non-invasively at scale that would have
seemed like science fiction two decades
ago
um
so i think that is going to affect
people's lives and there are so many
myths and misunderstandings about
what genetics can say and what it can't
say about psychological differences
between people so part of what i'm
trying to do this book is just to
explain
as a researcher and a professor in this
field like to the best of my ability
explain it in a way that's clear so that
people can understand and clear up some
of the myths
and then also
you know i
i have realized since i've been doing
this work for such a long period of time
that many people find it profoundly
unintuitive
to think that genetics matters and also
to consider yourself
a political liberal someone who's really
invested in the idea of social equality
as a as a political project
um and so
whereas those two things feel quite
consonant in my mind like they feel like
they fit together quite nicely
um and i've never you know in an
academic paper like you know it's four
thousand words you maybe have like a
thousand words for the discussion you
can maybe squeeze in like two sentences
somewhere
to explain an idea whereas a book gives
you space
to expound on something that um i think
is important that i think is
counterintuitive for many people
um that i think that i hope
changes the conversation like stretches
the conversation so that there's kind of
new space and it's not running in quite
the same tracks that it's been running
in
um for such a long time what do you mean
by social equality because that term is
very fraught
yes yes
um it's always equality of what so i
actually mean it quite
um quite simply
which is
what are the ways in which people's
lives
turn out differently in a society so if
we look at the end of people's lives we
can think
there's differences in physical health
how long do you live how physically
healthy are you your risk for disease
we can look at differences in
psychological well-being um
serious mental illness but also
depression and anxiety and well-being
and do you think your life is worth
living
um and then uh more economic outcomes so
we can think about income or wealth
or labor market participation
levels of education
what's interesting about those three
domains
of inequality of outcome
now compared to previous times in human
history
is that in the u.s and in the uk
they're really bound up with one another
and in really bound up in particular
with education
so if we look back
several hundred years ago at the
lifespans of nobility versus commoners
you didn't actually see that people who
were at the top of the pecking order
lived that much longer than
commoners like the plague came for them
all right like they were communicable
diseases were the primary cause of death
and
you know that you didn't have these huge
disparities in physical health
whereas now what you see is that you
know the most educated people they don't
just make more money they live longer
they live healthier lives
and they enjoy their lives more and i
think when you start thinking about that
cluster of inequality in which a very
educated slice of the population is
getting more of everything
those are the types of social
inequalities that i'm really interested
in
what's the sort of outcome
that you would want from this because we
can't flatten
society for everything you can't just
have this homogenous gray sort of
top color painted across everything it
can't be vanilla all the way down yeah
no and i don't want it to be i mean i
think there must be some constraints at
what point do you uh do where does the
boundary lie for what you consider
should be something which is within this
sort of mandate yeah yeah
so i think when we're thinking about um
like this question of like what should
be equalized right like oftentimes
people immediately go to resources right
like should we equalize income or should
we equalize
opportunities to go to college
and i think you know the scale of
inequality and income particularly in
the u.s like we could argue is
inefficient and a problem
what i'm more interested in is
equality of like
one kind of basic things that we owe to
fellow humans as kind of
as a kind of a necessary part of
reflecting their human dignity so a huge
thing in the us is healthcare right that
like millions of people don't have
access to the healthcare they can't go
to the doctor when they're sick
um i think nothing explains america and
american poverty quite so much as seeing
you know fill your own dental cavity
kits in walmart right like those are the
sorts of things where it doesn't really
matter to me
like whether or not you've not gone far
in school because you didn't have the
ability
versus you just didn't care about like
you just you know like you're just bored
by it and you'd rather do something else
like you'd rather be a mechanic than a
chemist like go forth in life
there are things that you still are
think are owed as part of being just
being a human in our society
um
that right now we really do particularly
in america structure according to
education in a way that i think is
unnecessary and we don't have to look
that far
to other you know high-income countries
that say
um you know
we want people to go far in school we
think it's instrumentally useful to you
know have people who do certain things
get paid more
we're not going to send you home to die
if you have cancer because you don't
have health insurance right like i think
there's really basic things like that
i also think there's you know
this increasing
um
like disrespect and sort of degradation
of prestige for the types of labor
that aren't the sort of things that like
i do right like i'm really good at
rotating abstract information in my head
and like working in a computer
that's not manual skill that's not
emotional labor like in service of
retail or waitressing which was you know
waitressing was the hardest job i ever
had in my life um
so we have these narratives right now
around like essential workers
who don't have control over their
schedule who don't have access to health
insurance who don't have like the kind
of
financial stability that allows them to
think i could have a family like i could
own a home
um
and that's not because their labor isn't
valuable to society it's because we've
devalued that labor
so those are like those kind of things
about like
healthcare
freedom from financial anxiety like
having enough material security so that
you feel like you can get married and
start a family
like not being constantly evicted from
your home
we can think about equalizing those and
it's not some soviet dystopia right like
that's not like a gray like that's like
finland right like i'm describing things
that do exist in the world
um but that are forms of inequality like
really persistent inequality that um
that we justify often particularly in
america according to these guidelines of
like meritocracy in education
explain to me the link between that and
genetics and dna because to me that just
sounds like policies that the government
needs to sort like we've got we've got
the nhs in the uk so we fix the
healthcare problem you put ubi in
therefore you fix the
uh the income problem the prestige thing
is a cultural
um
artifact of the way that people view
particular different jobs so you'd have
to have some sort of retraining so these
to me i don't see the link between that
uh and the genetics yeah yeah no i mean
like it's such a like that's such a good
observation because i i feel like what
you're picking up on is like
part of why
i get surprised when people think that
i'm a very controversial thinker because
like my bottom line on the offer many
things is
you know there should be a floor
there should be a social safety net
beyond which people can't
fall
which isn't hugely controversial in
large segments of the population
i think where genetics comes in is in
two ways so the first is
you know even if you're even if we say
regardless of how people do in school
they should have a certain access to a
quality of certain quality of life
um we're still also interested in
improving the how people do in school
we're still interested in improving how
children learn and
a big part of the book is invested in
describing
how ignoring genetics makes that project
harder like if we do research
that's predicated on the assumption that
children are all genetically the same
when they're not like the research base
on which we're building our policies and
interventions to try to help children
succeed in education
have predictable problems which is that
they don't were like what are the
genetic differences in outcomes based on
genetic markers
yeah so i mean just to back up a second
like if we look at um
you know there's kind of two ways to
study this and so one is just looking at
twins or adoptive adopt adoptees so
looking at family members who differ in
their genetic and social relationships
in some way and those of those types of
studies have long suggested that
you know
things like intelligence test score
performance but also personality traits
like conscientiousness and planfulness
educationally relevant disorders like
adhd or conduct problems
are all heritable which means that like
part of the reason why children are
different on these things is because
they have different genes
and then more recently there have been
studies that
identify specific genetic variants so
specific dna differences between people
that are correlated with these different
outcomes
and it's you know the that science has
progressed
so
rapidly that it's really forced social
scientists to pay attention to it
because now these genetic markers
are as strongly correlated with say the
likelihood of going to university
as
variables like family income are so
what's the sort of correlation that you
find
between
either parents and children or genetic
markers and outcomes in iq or academics
yeah
yeah so when we're talking so i guess
like there's a number of different
numbers you can throw around like i
would say like the maybe a touchstone is
to think about like what is the
correlation between
a polygenic score
which is you know kind of a summary of
someone's dna information
it's capturing environmental processes
but it's calculated just from your their
dna
and
rates of college completion in the us
and that correlation is like between
0.25 and 0.3
um
which isn't huge but is about the same
size as you get between like family ses
and going to college
you can make that number smaller by
being like well what is the correlation
when you're looking at within siblings
you can make that correlation bigger
when you're like well that's not
capturing all the genetics what if
you're looking at everything not just
what's measured in a polygenic score
um
you know the
that's like an active area of scientific
debate like
i think what's important is whatever the
number is it's not zero right there are
meaningful
genetically
associated differences between children
in the outcomes that we care about
really at every every stage of the
educational process so like robert
ploman in the uk who i know you've had
on has like with this with regards to
um like exam scores at age 16.
i've looked at it in relation to like
which math class do you get tracked into
in the ninth grade
um we can predict whether or not people
stay in math even knowing their grades
in their previous year from their dna
right so like among students we're all
in the same school and they all got b's
like the dna predicts which ones stay in
math versus drop out of math
so as soon as we're talking about
those types of correlations in the 0.2
to 0.3 range they're not large but none
of our correlations for things that we
measure in kids like school going
are large um and we can start to like
use them in our studies
um so that was i
feel like we've we fell in a little
tangent i don't remember the original
question but basically we now can
we now can measure dna
and assess its association with
outcomes we really care about
still with a great deal of uncertainty
but with enough certainty
that we can see that it is making a
difference right and
at the same time most of the kind of
work in child development is not paying
attention to that right so it's
continuing to study
parenting or school environments or
neighborhood environments in relation to
child outcomes
and there's this huge flaw at the heart
of so much of that research which is
that children get more than their
environments from their parents
and
that flaw is really holding us back from
designing better interventions designing
better policies to help children succeed
in school
so to put that together my argument is
kind of two-pronged which is that i
think we need genetics in order to
do the sort of science to help children
succeed
and at the same time knowing that
genetics makes a difference
is not some huge barrier to
the political project of improving
people's lives there that you know as
you said like you have the nhs like you
don't need genetics for that and both of
those things can be true at the same
time
i had a conversation after the robert
ploman episode went up and i i got to
uh how would you say i got to circle the
outside of the whirlwind briefly uh
while that one went up
uh the one that you sit in the middle of
sometimes and
uh a buddy
replied who's very familiar with the
behavioral genetics research and he said
thousands and thousands of parenting
books out there zero that include
behavioral genetics research one book on
behavioral genetics beats five books on
normal developmental parenting
and that
sort of really hit it home for me i was
like that
it makes a lot of sense
what i'm interested to try and find out
is
what
what are you proposing okay we can make
some sort of predictions based on
genetic markers about a child's
uh predisposition in school they are
going to be good at maths or [ __ ] at
english or maybe they're just going to
be higher iq lower iq maybe they're
autistic maybe whatever whatever like
what do you propose
that people do from there schools
policymakers
yeah so i propose i would say three
general things i think the first is my
fellow researchers
who are writing the stuff that goes into
the parenting books high income parents
do this and that makes their kids better
they should be routinely integrating
something about genetics into their
research so long as they're trying to
figure out what aspects of parenting or
school environments or neighborhood
environments like actually make a
difference for children's lives
it's not that nothing makes a difference
it's that
kind of reverse engineering
what are the actual ingredients of
change in effective schools and
effective parents in
you know in neighborhoods that foster
achievement that are opportunity zones
that's a really hard scientific problem
and we can be making better progress at
solving that
if
in the same way that researchers like
routinely control for socioeconomic
status when they're trying to say
reading to kids matters like let's make
genetics part of like the the everyday
working work a day arsenal of social
scientists
i think for policymakers
um and interventionists that are doing
policy evaluation or randomized
controlled trials of educational
interventions anyone that's like doing
an experiment
tinkering with something and seeing if
it works
i also think that they should be when
they can including genetic information
so that they can get beyond just seeing
does an intervention work on average for
the average child and instead get at are
the interventions i'm trying
serving the most vulnerable serving the
kids who are most at risk for poor
outcomes so moving beyond this the focus
on the average kid that doesn't exist to
heterogeneity of intervention effects
heterogeneity of policy evaluation
and then i think the third thing is like
you know
again i won't speak to the uk context
because i don't live there i don't live
in that political climate like i live in
texas i live in a state in which
people
are often very opposed to any idea of
redistribution
and very pro-meritocracy
and buttress those political beliefs
with a really earnest commitment to the
idea that any success they have they
earned it
and i would like people to consider the
role of luck
and in a particular genetic luck in
their successes and think about
if
if
this is in part because you got lucky
rather than because you're good what
does that mean about your commitments to
other people i just want people to
consider that question and take it
seriously
how would you differentiate between look
and
effort
effort i mean it's kind of an impossible
thing because i think you know what you
see is that
our genes shape our personality and then
our personality shapes um
what we
how much effort we put into well this
was a this is a question that i was
going to say so let's say that you had
two students in the same school with
similar genetic predispositions for
maths and english and stuff and one
works harder than the other is that a
problem well if conscientiousness has a
genetic marker in it then you go okay do
we need to somehow control
for the child's predisposition at
working hard like yeah
questions out of the window with regards
to free will
for a philosophical debate like
what's left on the table for us to
actually bear as alright i mean you're
you're exactly right like there there's
a great essay by the philosopher thomas
nagel and it's about this question of
moral luck right which things that are
lucky but that we're still responsible
for and it was like if we take
you know if we eliminate
kind of the role of luck in human lives
like what's left over shrinks to an
extensionless point right there's
essentially nothing left once we start
to take into this account that like
lock shapes personality which shapes
effort like there's no getting rid of
luck in your life
um for me
what that says and i you know i'm
borrowing this idea from political
philosophers um you know the philosopher
john roll said none of our precepts of
justice tilt towards desert which is
basically what was saying like this
whole political project of trying to
figure out like what people deserve and
what people earn
in order to justify inequality
is bound to fail because there is no
separating like effort from luck it's
turtles all the way down
what we should thinking be thinking
about is
you know what inequality is
instrumentally useful right like
rewarding some people more for certain
types of work is better for everyone if
it increases certain types of um
productivity or is more efficient in the
allocation of certain goods or resources
that's a different argument than saying
i deserve my salary because i'm so
clever right like
um so i'm not trying to say like i'm not
trying to disappear agency out of
people's lives
i'm trying to get people to consider
that
if they are quote unquote successful in
the sense that they enjoy a certain
level of economic goods in our like
winner takes all meritocratic rat race
um
that looking to their own lives and
thinking about how much they deserve it
and earn it might be
missing part of the story
if you as a scientist are struggling to
be able to
bifurcate those two the person
themselves with all of their biases and
their self-love it's essentially an
impossible task and they'll be
someone who's worked really hard or
feels like they've worked really hard
and has overcome their demons and
they've had setbacks and they've had
this that and the other and they've
fought their way to the top
my business partner's standing on the
shoulder of his children's names to try
and climb out of the working class in
the middle class and whatever it is that
they do to try and get there and then
they think well hang on a second are you
telling me that i should have somehow
been pulled further back because i had a
starting line head start genetically
this was me this was my agency this is
what i did there's a concern that people
feel like they're just
outcomes are going to be taken away from
them
yeah so i feel like that's i mean that's
such an interesting and we've gotten so
far away from genetics but this idea
that it's
that by equality we mean leveling down
or by equality we mean pulling back or
by equality we mean
taking things away from them
um
versus
the ways in which
everyone even the person even the person
at the top
is better off when things are more equal
and this is something that like i think
can be profoundly counterintuitive
um
but we see as true that like people who
live in more unequal societies are less
happy
they're more anxious even when they're
at the top of the hierarchy because
there's this still sense of like felt
precarity i have to maintain like at all
times like i can't let myself fall down
or my children fall down
you know this the idea that everything
in life
is this relentless competition
um with no no margin for error
it doesn't just hurt the losers of the
competition it also hurts the winners
um you know i i
genuinely think that like
jeff bezos
in the long term
will be better off if he has like
100 million fewer dollars but lives in a
society
in which there's more political
stability
and like fewer supply chain issues for
amazon because like laborers who unload
the boxes are like adequately paid
enough and not dying of covet like
there are ways in which
it's not actually a zero-sum game when
we are talking about like equality and
people immediately go to this like
you're trying to take something away
from people at the top that's the topic
by inequality too yeah i uh i got sent a
study by rob henderson just before i
came on and he said that
people
in
low class the lower classes
are more concerned with policies that
raise up poverty
but people in the upper classes are more
concerned with policies that reduce
inequality
lower classes want poverty reducing but
upper classes want inequality reducing
that seem quite surprising to me
yeah i know that's interesting i haven't
read that study but
you know people have like
i you know i also wonder like to what
extent that's about
what aspects of inequality or
are most affecting you right so
you know i'm a like an upper middle
class affluent person who lives in a
very unequal city
um
you know when i think about like what is
hurting austin
i think about like well how is the
concentration of wealth
warping the housing market how is the
concentration of wealth warping
like the educational system when people
can opt out of public schools and go to
private schools
um
whereas so that set of concerns
is really focused at like to what extent
is the concentration of wealth and like
the 0.01 percent
changing the conditions of livability
for all of us right
that's different from someone who is
existing like at the poverty line and is
really interested in like how can i make
sure that like i have secure housing and
i have secure food and like i can send
my kids to school at all
um ultimately though i think our
our concerns about both alleviating
poverty and eliminating inequality
there's points of political intersection
between those like you know particularly
around like housing and affordable
housing um but i do think that's really
interesting like you know whether you're
whether you're more interested and like
compressing the scale of inequality writ
large versus specifically raising the
floor like people have different
priorities around that for sure
getting back to genetics then what are
some of the more surprising correlations
that you found asura i saw a bit about
when identical twin sisters have
marriages with different levels of
conflict their children have equal risk
for delinquency what are some of the
other ones yeah
well i mean that project is part of like
most of my graduate work which was
attempting to address this problem that
we've talked about before
and the problem being that most studies
just correlate aspects of parenting and
child outcomes and then are like
oh this aspect of parenting is like the
secret sauce right so
you know there's eight million studies
that are
parents who fight more have more
behavior problems like this is why you
should learn to get along with your
spouse more because it's going to help
your kids adhd
and like very few considering that like
argumentative parents might have
argumentative children like for reasons
other than just environmental modeling
um so my graduate work was a lot on like
kind of divorce murder conflict age at
childbearing like you know as teenage
pregnancy like actually bad for kids um
what did you come up with
um it suggests that like teenage moms
definitely face a lot more
like financial problems than mothers
usually childbearing like there's
there's um you know there's a penalty to
early motherhood in terms of education
in the labor market
um but the effect of adolescent
parenthood on kids particularly their
like um content problems and adhd is a
lot smaller than people might anticipate
and you know and that's because
um people do not have children as
teenagers at random right so like more
impulsive sensation-seeking moms are
more likely to have kids young and
they're more likely to have impulsive
sensation-seeking kids
um so there's just a lot like going back
to your you know there's eight million
parenting books
which are all like here all the things
correlated with people like a high and
high income white lady basically is what
they're they're all saying um and very
few of those things are shown to
actually have like a causal impact on
child development like it's just like
let's see what's in fashion amongst
people in a certain social class and
then like
give us give give parents a lot of
advice
based on that not really on like tons of
solid science i couldn't believe that
girls who hit puberty earlier are less
likely to do maths
oh that that was surprising to you well
you weren't a girl i guess yeah i didn't
i didn't think that if you're a girl who
hits puberty sooner
the boys that are in the maths class are
going to hit on you because you're the
one that's developing and it makes
complete it makes complete sense i don't
disbelieve it for a moment but i was
like oh yeah but that's because
when
girls go from being a girl to being a
woman
something
so
attractive happens to the boys that are
looking at them when boys go from being
boys to men nothing happens like
essentially nothing changes their voice
just gets a bit weird and they get
spotty
so it's so interesting you know i just
taught my adolescent development lecture
because i teach intro psych which is
great to teach adolescent development
because they're all freshmen right so
they're 18 they just went through this
some of them are still going through
this
and i teach a really big online class
and so i put them into chat rooms all
the time where they can talk to each
other and i was like so they're chat
prompt was
do you wish you could have gone through
earlier through puberty earlier or later
and all of the girls are like i wish
that it happened later like i was the
first one in my class it was
embarrassing it was discouraging men are
skeevy boys start to look at you totally
differently like
you know my parents treated me
differently which is true like the
research literature show like girls go
through puberty a little earlier than
boys anyways and so the earliest
maturing girls
look like women and the boys in their
class look like boys
um
but that doesn't stop the boys from
being but creepy to them in a lot of
ways and so whereas the boys were like i
couldn't wait like my voice cracked and
i was like when is the rest of this i
still can't grow a beard i'm still
waiting for this
and i think it's interest i mean i think
it's actually a great example of like
there's what genes do to your body and
then there's
how society responds to your body right
like
going through puberty is very heritable
you know like that's kind of like a
developmental timing thing
um but then you have
breasts and hips and your your social
environment and your teachers and your
parents are responding to you
differently
and so it's
um we sometimes use the phrase
environmentally mediated genetic effects
like it's the effect of your genes on
your body that then becomes like the
grist for this social nil and like the
social response that you're getting for
people
and so
when you see that like girls who go
through puberty early or less likely to
take advanced math classes is that a
genetic effect well like going through
puberty earlier is genetic
but then there's also like the social
construction of girlhood
and
of
sexual gender dynamics between
adolescents that like is responsible for
that outcome that highlights exactly
what i was saying earlier on that
there's two elements at play there you
can try and control for the culture
or you can try and control for the
genetics because the outcome or the the
impact that you're trying to avoid is
something which occurs culturally but
there's two ways that we can play around
with this you know do you need to have a
maths class for all of the girls that
are early developers like oh it looks
like looks like we're just on math plus
for all of the girls right like to just
not be in you know to just uh to be able
to be in stem education free of uh men
who dominate the conversation right like
some people have attempted to you know
does that matter for girls outcomes yeah
absolutely and then think about some of
the externalities that you might have
from that then you would have women who
eventually end up in the workplace and
haven't had sufficiently long to be able
to work out how to communicate with men
and men who wouldn't understand how to
communicate with women and from what i
know the men in stem could do with a bit
of
assistance with
learning how to talk to women in any
case so
right what about homelessness you were
talking about austin and obviously
there's i've seen quite a lot of stories
about the homelessness problem in austin
and you also researched that and it's
links to
genetics well yeah i mean so
homelessness isn't is a problem that's
exactly i mean in many ways just like
puberty right which is not like
homelessness is just like puberty
you heard it
that we have here in the sense that
there's
genetic effects on people's
biology
and then there's how our social and
legal environment responds to that so
we know that there are genetic
influences on mental illnesses like
schizophrenia and we also know that
in the u.s
a serious mental illness is one of the
biggest risk factors for
um being homeless and there's a long
history behind that right like we had a
massive d investment in psychiatric care
in the united states we had a big
de-institutionalization movement of like
shutting down the inpatient wards and
like getting people out of hospital
um
we don't have enough psychiatric beds or
public housing in the united states and
so what happens to someone who's
seriously mentally ill and whose family
doesn't have enough resources to pay for
psychiatric health care for them they're
very likely to end up on the streets
um
austin has been in this terrible like
we're gonna criminalize camping we're
not gonna we're gonna decriminalize
camping we're gonna recriminalize
camping and it's like just fussing
around at the symptoms of the problem
right like it's not
the problem isn't whether or not an
unhoused person can use a tent it's that
they don't have a house and we haven't
addressed as a society
the structural
issues that go into them being
unemployed unhoused
so again we have like
you know your genes affect your risk of
experiencing psychotic symptoms
it's our social choice that people with
psychotic symptoms are on the street
instead of in the hospital like the
biggest psychiatric care provider in the
united states is the jail system like
more schizophrenics are in prison versus
like in hospital
um so
that is like we can think about genes to
biology and then
what's happening to a person in their
social environment based on that biology
um homelessness is a is a great example
of that
there's another element where you're
talking about separating characteristics
and the difference between how
valued some characteristics are and how
valuable someone is in society can you
dig into that
yeah i mean i think when we're when
we're talking about
um intelligence when we're talking about
homelessness when we're talking about
conscientiousness
um when we're talking about
uh economists often use the word skilled
skilled labor
there can be this idea that if
traits are associated with genes
then that's evidence that some people
are sort of inherently more valuable
than other people right that they're
genetically smarter they're genetically
more
moral or whatever
and i don't think that's true i think
what we see is that there's
a wide variety of
genetic differences between us and also
a wide variety of skills and talents and
traits
and then we now live in a in a system
that
systematically values some skills and
traits over others right like going back
to you talking about you and your friend
growing up working class
you know why do we think of being a
university professor as being a quote
unquote better job than being a mechanic
right like we can't really function very
well as a society without mechanics like
we need mechanical knowledge
but it is
it is a type of training and a type of
skill that's devalued relative to
you know maybe what a university
professor is doing what kind of skills
they have
and what i'm trying to call attention to
is that that's not some
fixed and inflexible like law of nature
that is
choices that we've made as a society
right but to say like if you have these
skills you have access to these types of
jobs that come with these types of
material conditions and if you have
these skills you're allowed to hoard all
sorts of wealth and opportunity
there's nothing
like fixed in
fixed in nature about that that is the
result of social choices so i do agree
however
i i would struggle to justify saying
that the guy that sits on his couch
in his house of three other dudes
smoking weed and playing xbox all day
is as valuable as as contributive of a
member of society as the mechanic or the
university professor or the bus driver
or anybody else right like
i understand that you can say this is
gene's an environment for most of the
way down that this person is the
the nail on the end of the finger of the
arm of the position that they were given
of the life that they've been leading
that's currently being grown out of the
earth
but
i i can't
what about the freeloader the house is
out there the rubber has the rubber has
to meet the road at some point it's like
look we have to make people culpable for
some of the things that they do
yeah so we i mean we definitely already
do that right like i would say like
you know in terms of
people being
people giving not being given many
chances and people
being at high risk for experiencing a
lot of poverty and admiseration
um if they're not quote unquote
contributing like i feel like that's in
many ways like a defining feature of the
american political landscape
um and people you know that sense of
like that
like it's not fair if they're rewarded
when they're not contributing is a very
like
basic moral intuition that i'm not
really trying to push against right like
my children have that like my daughter
if i'm like you both have to go clean up
your room and then you can watch tv and
my daughter does most of the work
cleaning up the room she is i think
outraged if her brother also gets to
watch television she's like but he just
sat there while i did all the work like
why does he get to watch tv like that
sense of outrageousness over
um
you know children are outraged by unfair
inequality but they're also outraged by
what they consider to be equality that's
unfair to like unfair equality like if
people get the exact same for a
different effort like children get
really mad about that too
there's two things i want to like just
add to that which is
one
what do we owe even the slacker on the
couch by virtue of him being a human
right and like he probably isn't owed
um a yacht and a million dollar 401k but
like are we gonna send him home from the
hospital are we gonna
tell him to pull his own teeth right
like though like what do we owe people
even who are slackers even who are bad
like even who aren't quote unquote
contributing
i don't think we pay enough attention to
that at least in where i live
and the second is
um my colleagues pamela hurd and don
moynihan have written a great book on
administrative burden which is
like what are the costs of administering
social programs when you're trying to
separate the deserving applicants from
the undeserving applicants
and basically their research suggests
that
even though freeloaders bother us
we can end up hurting ourselves and the
people who actually need help
more
by putting in this administrative
machinery that like is trying to suss
out like is this person a mechanic or is
this person you know the video gamer on
his couch right so
not universalizing things
even though it does activate our like
very six-year-old impulses of like but
someone might not get something even
when they're slacker and they're not
doing anything
like
not universalizing things can
make programs more expensive and end up
so that the people who do need them are
less likely to get them and so at the
end of the day i'm just kind of a
consequentialist about this in which i
feel like
um you know i'd rather a guilty man go
free than an innocent man be in jail and
like i would rather have someone who is
like undeserving of a social benefit get
it
then
have a whole machinery in place that
ends up hurting people who like
to have legitimate claims on a service
um
so those really good
yeah i think that's a really good
identification of
why
people who lean left
tend to be compassionate
i think that's like the best
summarization that i've ever seen for
that um because for me i think my
indignation would overtake my empathy
i i think that
i would
i don't know if i would be prepared
the guilty man going free versus the
innocent man going to jail like that's
you know that's that's a much tighter
decision for me to make it's more
difficult for me to work out where i lie
on that um
what i thought was really interesting
was you talking about
unfair equality as well as unfair
inequality um and that's what we're
talking about with that indignation the
hypocrisy the concerns around undeserved
it it definitely feels to me i would be
really interested to see where your
viewpoints are
let's say that we get the sort of
progress that we're hoping for
economically in terms of welfare and
poverty levels and so on and so forth um
over the next 20 years 30 years i'll be
really really interested to see
what your um stance would be on this
let's say that we raise the floor of
welfare so that everybody has basic
human dignity right now one of the
problems is that we're not rational
creatures
a lot of the time
we're more concerned
relatively about our position within the
hierarchy than absolutely yeah
and i'm sure that you've considered this
because if you offer someone you can
make an extra fifty thousand dollars
yourself or you can make an extra
hundred thousand dollars but all of your
competitors make an extra 120 000
people will take the objective lower
number so that relatively they gain more
status this is how we are wired so for
me my concern is that
it's status games all the way down now
yeah so i so i feel like
this is where
this is a really interesting question
like i i'm not really interested in
changing
aspects of our psychology that are
probably like pretty deeply evolved
right like are we going to get rid of
getting rid of that hierarchy is in
competition like no we're not going to
um
it's more about like
what structures can we build
that satisfy and respond to those
psychological needs
that also take seriously these other
moral concerns right and
um
it's like so the economist robert frank
has a really great book called success
and luck which is not about genetics
it's about like environmental luck like
random opportunities that come to you
and this is a
you know a topic that he takes really
seriously
around like
someone's always gonna want a bigger
boat like it doesn't matter how big the
yacht is like someone's gonna always
want a bigger boat like there's there's
going to be no like undoing of male
psychology that like makes them not want
the bigger boat at the end of the day
and so he's like so what could we do
with that and he has a whole proposal
around like a consumption tax which like
doesn't actually really change the
utility that people at the top end of a
of an economic hierarchy get out of like
the status competition around goods
but does like redistribute wealth and
like prevent this kind of like runaway
inflation of like the cost of some like
some things that affect other people's
uh prices like housing markets and
that's the sort of thing that i'm
interested in if we raise the floor up
so that the redistribution basically is
no longer required what are we talking
about there if the people who aren't
putting the work in aren't putting the
work in but are living a life which is
morally
uh how would you say respectable uh by
the the particular values that you've
given um i i don't know i don't know
what we're achieving there other than
reducing
the
imperative
or the incentive
for those people to actually do
something this is one of the concerns
that you have like the free rider
freeloader problem right the tragedy of
the commons is one of the things that
comes out of it
yeah so it's i mean
it's so interesting to me to hear you
talk because i feel like
i mean you're bringing up like is
inequal like
i mean i think this is a really fun
animal debate like to what extent like
as inequality itself a bad thing versus
like we're just concerned about the
minimum but also like to what extent is
a work a good thing like a lot of your
comments are predicated on this idea
that like work
work qua work productivity is better
than leisure
which is just like i'm not necessarily
sure i'm even like taking that
like as an assumption like i you know
the the dream of
technology was it was going to make work
easier so that we all had more time for
leisure the we the next boys
you know that we could all be iceland
and be like okay we now have a four day
work week like that's you know the
vision that i have
of like
what world would i want my children to
enjoy
you know
in this utopia that you've described
where like poverty no longer exists and
like people have like you know a basic
income and access to health care
um
is not one in which there are still
pressures to work 70 hours a week as
part of
um
being part of a prestigious occupation
like
uh
at what point do we start to value
leisure
in addition to work
that's that's a [ __ ] fascinating
question because
so much of our self-worth
especially if you're industrious and
conscientious so much of your self-worth
is
tied to
the work that you do and you can
actually even shortcut the outcome the
outcomes and the output of the work and
it can just simply be that like the
puritan work ethic like i am i take
pleasure from the sheer suffering
that is a part of the work i do you can
imagine these priests in the middle ages
they're hoeing hoeing the garden outside
of the church and the sun's beating down
on their backs but they're doing it in
service to god and this is us we're
doing it in service to moloch right like
that's that's what we're here for here's
here's one for you i mean i
like i find this so fast right like why
do we have i mean the theory about the
quote-unquote protestant work ethic is
like well the calvinists were like well
you were predestined before the dawn of
time to be either in the elect or not in
the elect and you weren't gonna know but
like one way to show yourself and other
people that you were in the elect like
that you weren't gonna go to hell is
that like your sign of god's blessings
which is the accrual of wealth right and
so and then we've moved into secularism
and just like taken the god part out of
it but haven't taken the like i'm
i spend all my time working and accruing
wealth as a sign that i'm somehow good
like why are we
we need to be interrogating that more a
lot more i think in terms of where our
sense of self-worth comes from because
it's not coming from the church anymore
um here's one for you
if we could should we go into the genes
and flatten them so that everyone has
the same genetic opportunity because
we're trying to achieve this socially so
why not try and achieve it genetically
so i
i there's a great line from javanski who
was a evolutionary biologist and the
early i mean in the mid 20th century and
he wrote in science in 1962 that genetic
diversity is mankind's most precious
resource
um
and i believe that like i
don't what i want is
a society that is more like a meadow
than a lot of grass like in where we
have many different people with many
different talents which a lot of
diversity that are working in
cooperation
and
it's
beautiful and not homogeneous right that
that is a quality of thriving not a
quality of
genomes right like whereas a lawn is a
monoculture like i'm not like
monocultures in agriculture never work
out like they never they're never good
bad things happen when we have
monocultures and i don't think that
there's you know the problem with with
society in my view right now is that we
have so narrowly defined to skill
that
we have kind of a monoculture of skill
and talent um amongst who was considered
like the top of the like elite or of a
status hierarchy of an income hierarchy
whereas you know one phrase that people
use for it is like a pluralistic
opportunity structure where there's many
different genetically influenced talents
that can all
like different routes to success those
are the sorts of
um social structures that i think are
good
i'll never forget this meme it's so
useful i've never been able to find it
again there's this guy this really big
guy and he's sort of maybe about my age
early 30s or whatever like
pretty good looking dude and he's got a
shirt and tie on he stood at the front
of a bed bath and beyond and he's just
sort of welcoming this woman welcoming
this woman to a department store and
there's a thought bubble going out of
his head and it says 500 years ago i
would have been a strong warrior
yeah yeah i mean and i think
you know i like i'm
i was like i'm a woman and i you know
i'm raising a nine-year-old but i'm not
an expert on minute masculinity
but i do think just from my observations
of my undergraduates when we look at
rates of college completion when we look
at like political
disaffection amongst young men
this sense of
i do have something to contribute i
don't want to be the person that's like
sitting on my couch playing video games
um but i do there isn't an opportunity
structure
for me to feel like the skills and
talents i do have
are valuable are prestigious
are gonna like create a life for myself
in which i can have a family and that i
think is a huge problem from a gendered
perspective i'm going to guess that
boys on average tend to sit still with
more difficulty in classes
higher rates of adhd so on and so forth
more anti-social behavior
yeah i mean that's all true and then i
think particularly
you know when we're talking about like
you know male adolescence and male
puberty like this is a period of a
lifespan in which
adolescents generally but male
adolescents in particular
are really developmentally primed for
risk for feeling like things have stakes
and we put them in high schools that are
like the most boring things ever and
then they all say i've never been more
bored
i have no you know we have closed off
all opportunities
you know unless we're talking about
military service when they turn 18
for people to experience
like pro-social
positively socially sanctioned forms of
risk and adventure taking and then we
wonder why like male adolescents drop
out of school and go to college at lower
rates and female adolescents like across
the board
like we don't take their developmental
needs seriously like we just actually
are kind of terrible to teenagers
generally um in terms of taking like we
treat them as like deficient adults
rather than like this is a unique period
of the lifespan that has its own
developmental needs like how we
how would we design a school if we
actually didn't hate teenagers that's a
really good point because we we molly
cuddle children and they're still cute
and there's there's still this level of
protectionism around them and yeah you
you bestow on teenagers the
responsibility
and the standards that you expect from
an adult
with all of the resentment of a child
that has agency not behaving the way
that they should do yeah yeah no it's
true like in my class i give my students
like a list of like hero rights and
responsibilities of adulthood you know
like you can get married you can be
tried as an adult for a crime you can
rent a car you can drink alcohol you can
join the military
and i'm like i want you to
if you were dictator for the day and
what age
should we be able to do these things
um
and then at what age do we actually do
them right and it's like in texas you
can be tried as an adult for a felony
10 years before you can rent a car like
that's
insane from a developmental science
perspective and what we do
is we hold them responsible for making
adult-like decisions
and when we're trying to punish them
but we withhold the rights that come
from being an adult like such as voting
or drinking
um as late as possible and then we
wonder why adolescents are resentful of
adults like well because you treat them
like petulant children all the time and
don't design anything for their sake so
um i could go on and on about this but
like we we don't take
adolescence seriously in our cultures
and i think that's a real shame
frederick duboa who wrote the cult of
smart he agrees that genes and luck play
big roles and life outcomes and as a
result he's a strong supporter of
communism are you tempted by communism
um i think that freddie would describe
himself as a socialist not a communist
um and i think it's interesting because
i think his you know i think his
socialist um i don't know freddie very
well just you know mostly well enough to
call him freddie
um well we've been on like a symposium
together before and he um
[Music]
he
i you know i'm pretty sure his political
commitments like predate any interest in
genetics um which i think is an
important point which is that
you know
observing that there are genetic
differences between people
it doesn't commit you to any
moral or political project i think it's
more
um
you know given a moral political project
what constraints about the real world do
i need to take into account when i'm
thinking about
you know how to bring this about and so
i mean that's been very much my case too
i was
an egalitarian before i was a behavior
geneticist
have you read the book why white run
slower
no
okay so this french guy he looked at
athletic performance largely being
determined by genetics and there was
this act n3 the sprint gene
and there's an rr form for speed in an
rx form for endurance have you seen this
so i have read about this um do you know
if there's any truth in it
so i so my sources of knowledge about
this are two books one is david
epstein's the sports gene
which is fantastic i really recommend it
and he is that book is all about the
genetics of athletic performance um
in very like in various capacities and
various specific genes and i think
what's
interesting about his book
is
um
you know i know david only through
twitter like he wrote that book years
before i wrote mine it's on a completely
different domain of human skill which is
athletics versus education
um but thematically it actually ends up
in a very similar place which is like
yes genes matter figuring out which
genes matter is really hard
and it's never just genes right like
this is such a complicated complicated
developmental story um
and then the other source of information
about genetics and sports that i have
read is adam rutherford's how to argue
with a racist which um spends a lot of
time on these kind of stories about like
why some racial groups are quote-unquote
better at some sports than others
and his up basically the same place that
epstein's does which is
like
you know if you pick like one gene in
one comparison it can look so like such
a neat tidy story and then as soon as
you think about the larger picture of
athletic performance like those just
those stories kind of like fall apart
entirely
um so i don't you know like this is not
i don't
i don't know anything about the genetics
of sports performance other than reading
those two books so like
but you know my sense of it is
when it comes to really complex domains
of skill
these neat stories about like
populations in one gene almost never
hold up to like more sustained scrutiny
adam rutherford called me out after the
robert plowman episode he tweeted really
he tweeted something mean about me so
i'm not friends with him yeah exactly uh
anyway the genetic lottery if you were
no longer friends with anyone who said
something means you on twitter like in
my experience you would be like left
with no people like they're in the eye
of the storm there would be no one there
would literally be no one
the genetic lottery why dna matters for
social equality will be linked in the
show notes below and if people want to
try and bolster your dwindling twitter
world as people continue to clash up
against you where should they go
so i'm on twitter at
kph3k and you can find me i have a
website which is kpharden.com
thank you
all right thank you so much thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few months and don't forget to
subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace